First possession, he gets the ball, he shoots an air ball.
He misses like by six feet and I put my...
...hands on my head and I'm, "Oh please, Lord, just get him a basket."
One minute later, he got his hoop: a three-pointer that set the gym on fire.
I was very excited, the team was excited, everybody else is excited.
But JMc wasn't done.
He kept shooting and kept hitting, another three and another three.
I was on fire. I was hotter than a pistol.
When he was done, he hit the team record tying six three-pointers.
The crowd stormed the court and put Jason on their shoulders.
It was one of those special moments that, as an athletic director,...
...if I retired today, this would be the one thing that I talked about forever.
Jason's playing career is done but his celebrity continues at school.
Everybody, I was late to every single class.
Everybody was saying, "Congratulations!".